well plant smuggling can be a prickly
business especially when your spoils are
cacti
but in all seriousness the theft of some
species from chile's atacama desert
represents an existential threat to the
plants
now authorities in italy and chile have
cracked down
a horde of poached cactus plants stolen
from the atacama desert in chile
some of these prickly plants are
centuries old
the total haul discovered by the police
a year ago since returned home
is valued at over 1.2 million dollars on
the black market
to make this happen police from chile
and italy have worked together with the
association for biodiversity and
conservation for more than a year
poaching plants is becoming a problem
and it's a crime that threatens
biodiversity
plants are not very often
linked to extinction risk like when you
think about a threatened species you
usually don't think about a plant
and i think part of it is because
plants are everywhere so we take them
for granted even though
many more plant species are threatened
with extinction than
vertebrates the phenomenon is known as
plant blindness
hundreds of cacti species are more
threatened with extinction than birds or
mammals and
most people are not aware of it often
smugglers ease their way through
customs without hassle because even some
customs officers are not aware of the
illegal plant trade
but this time it's different the
confiscation and subsequent repatriation
of the plants have made headlines around
the world
it's raised awareness something that may
help prevent future cac
napping